well let's talk now to the trade
secretary Liam Fox who joins us from
central London good morning to you mr.
Fox good morning it is the eve of the
vote tomorrow do you think the
government will win it well the numbers
at the moment don't look particularly
favorable but the Prime Minister will be
requests to make a statement in the
House of Commons this afternoon setting
out the discussions she's had in recent
days with European leaders and the
reassurances that she's been able to get
on some of the issues that MPs are
concerned about notably around the eye
the backstop which is of course the
insurance policy that we have in case
we're unable to come to an agreement
with the European Union over the period
of the implementation period in the next
two years so numbers you admit and not
looking good at the moment so as it
stands before the prime minister utters
a word today looks like you'll lose well
we have to wait and see it depends on
our our MPs interprets what the Prime
Minister is going to say and we've got a
clear instruction from the voters which
is that we have to leave the European
Union Parliament gave that decision to
the people the people took that decision
Parliament must now have the humility to
carry that decision out in fact I would
say it's a matter of duty in a matter of
honor that we do so the question is how
do we do that now in front of us we have
the deal that the Prime Minister is
negotiated with European leaders it's
not the deal that everybody would want
but then probably no negotiation is but
it's a way in which we can carry out the
wishes of the British people with
minimal disruption in terms of our
economy the two other alternatives are
to leave with no deal at all or indeed
not to leave the European Union now I
think leaving with no deal while I think
it's entirely survivable for the UK
economy would be problematic in the
short term but I think no brexit would
create such a chasm between Parliament
and the voters that its consequences
would be unknowable yea the Prime
Minister is pulling out all the stops
today at the last minute on the eve of
the vote as she was to try and persuade
MP she's got the speech up in stoke
today and she's also making that
statement in the Commons on the Irish
border but as you mentioned there
the possibility of no brexit at all has
started to be talked about and the Prime
Minister is going to reference that in
her speech in stoke-on-trent today do
you think that's the likely outcome if
MPs reject her plans tomorrow I think
it's a possible outcome it's very clear
that there are a number of MPs who think
that they can defy the will of the
people they think that their opinions
seem to be more important than the
people who voted in the referendum I
take huge issue with that I think as I
said that we have a duty to carry out
the result of the referendum but there's
in it we have a parliament for the
majority of MPs themselves voted to
remain the question is whether they will
put their own opinions ahead of the
opinions of the seventeen point four
million people who voted to leave the EU
and you've said before that something
can be 5050 if this deal doesn't go
through
no brexit what are the odds on that in
your opinion then if this deal doesn't
get through how likely is it looking
it's impossible to say because it's tied
up with a lot of parliamentary procedure
but it certainly is possible because
there are quite a number of MPs who
would like that to be the outcome now I
think that you know when we had the
general election in 2017 both major
parties said that they would respect the
result of the referendum I think of MPs
individually now turned around and said
actually we're not even going to honor
our own manifestos nevermind the result
of the referendum itself I think you
will see a huge gulf between members of
parliament and the public and it's hard
to see how you would repair that damage
in terms of Parliament's reputation a
rebel MPs plotting against you there was
all that coverage in the Sunday papers
yesterday about mp's wrestling to take
control from the government in
Parliament to have a say on brexit Boris
Johnson in his column in The Telegraph
today has said that this plot is
nonsense what what are your views on MPs
actions to try and control the outcome
of what's going on oh it's not nonsense
there is definitely a group of MPs who
would want that to happen and I think
that we need to be realistic about the
potential options and should the Prime
Minister be unable to persuade
Parliament on her deal so to simply
dismiss it as unrealistic I know from
conversations that I've had that there
are a number of MPs who don't want
bricks it to happen at all some of whom
won't even be standing at the next
election so don't really care about the
electoral consequences to dismiss it I
think is not responsible okay I just
want to put some viewers questions to
you if I may I put out a tweet last
night we got lots of questions in for
you and this has come in from Macaulay
Mosley he said can we please ask him Fox
if he honestly believes that Theresa
Mae's deal will survive the meaningful
vote or is this a ploy the government
are using to run down the clock on the
brexit because you must emit all Tereza
May's actions are coming in the 24 hours
before this meaningful vote well I don't
believe that to be true the government
has been making a lot of attempts to
persuade members of parliament we had
had a number of days of debate on all
the issues across all the governmental
departments I'm leaving for the
government today on global Britain and
trade so there's been substantial debate
on this but we do want to come to a
conclusion and I do hope that tomorrow
MPs will bring this process to an end by
voting for the Prime Minister's deal if
we don't they'll be further uncertainty
yeah nothing about this breakfast
process is as easy as it may have looked
at the outset this is coming from Terry
boy on Twitter he says does Liam Fox
plan to apologise to voters after his
assurance for getting a deal with the EU
would be one of the easiest things in
human history what I said was the trade
agreement that we come to for our future
trading relationship with the European
Union should technically be easy because
we begin with exactly the same
regulations and exactly the same
legislation which we don't in any other
trade saying that but we're not but
we're not discussing the trade agreement
at the moment were discussing with
withdrawal agreements we cannot get the
negotiations on the future trading
relationship until we have their
withdrawal agreements in place that is
the key point and this has been about
the politics of it not the future
trading relationship
and this is from Sarah McEvoy she says
the public voted to leave the EU but
Teresa Mays deal ties us to them forever
the complete opposite of what we the
people voted for surely Parliament
cannot vote for a deal that goes totally
against what the public voted for there
has been one criticism hasn't it in
terms of Teresa Mays plan tying us to
the EU more then perhaps voters would
like well I don't believe it does that
but I've read these criticisms but or on
detailed questioning and do we have an
end to free movement and control of our
own borders yes we do do we have an end
to the oversight of the European Court
in terms of the British law yes we do
do we stop paying vast amounts of money
into the European Union after the end of
our implementation period yes we do in
my view it does give us the things that
I argued for and fought for in the very
long period when I was campaigning to
leave the European Union okay well thank
you to our viewers for tweeting in their
questions and thank you to you Liam Fox
for answering them just one before we go
we've just been looking through the
Prime Minister's speech that she'll be
making in Stoke later on and there's a
paragraph that stands out to us and
she's going to say imagine if an anti
devolution House of Commons had said to
the people of Scotland or Wales that
despite voting in favor of a devolved
legislature Parliament knew better and
would overrule them or else force them
to vote again Theresa May voted against
the bill to create the Welsh Assembly in
97 after the referendum that voted for
it as did you so it seems like a bit of
an odd example for the Prime Minister to
bring up in stating her case not at all
I think it's a very good example we were
on the losing side of that referendum
but we accepted that the public had
spoken and can you imagine what would
have happened if we had not been willing
to accept the verdict of the voters but
instead said Parliament knows best
and so Parliament should not say it
knows best now Parliament should do what
it was elected to do which was to
deliver or on the brexit referendum
that's our duty I think we are
honorbound to do so